[MUSIC]
[CHEER]
>> This primal, guttural chant
explodes to the throats of 250 boys and
girls signaling the start of the camp day.
But I have no idea what's going on.
I've arrived at camp a week late and
I feel lost.
Can you imagine that scared seven
year old trembling in the back row?
That's me.
Terrified, I won't belong.
Scared, I won't make friends.
That was 20 years ago, and
I was about to learn the lesson I
want to share with you all now.
The profound impact an invested
adult can have on a child's life.
For me, that adult was Tarzan Team.
Back in the summer of 2002 Tarzan Team
was the coolest guy around.
He wore Ray Bans and
a visor before the retro look was in.
He was bigger, faster and
stronger than everyone I can't.
In Tarzan Team set out to be my friend.
Me, that skinny seven-year-old,
had more anxiety in his gut
than he could handle himself.
I remember the way that Tarzan Team
made me feel, feel like I belonged.
He would say things like, whoa,
Mario sure knows how to make a mud ball.
You all should be asking him how he does
it Mario that's a fantastic dream catcher.
We'll have to hang it in our secret for
these small moments of investment
turned a terrifying experience into
a summer of social and emotional growth.
Tarzan Team invested in me,
and it transformed my life.
Summer Camp has the ability to inspire
transformative change on people's lives,
full stop.
The National Academy of Sciences
highlights summer camp benefits on child
safety, social, emotional well-being,
physical and mental health, and
academic learning.
An ongoing longitudinal study by
psychologist David Yeager indicates
that a mere one week at camp can increase
college attendance rates by 18%.
And that's one week.
Imagine the power of a full summer.
So the stats tell us we do good by our
children when we send them to camp with
a power of an invested
adult works wonders.
But that's not the only thing I'm
here to talk about with you today.
This is picture of me and Tarzan Team,
back in that fabled summer of 2002.
Beyond the smiles in
the mud stained shirts,
what stands out to me,
the general lack of ethnic diversity.
My memory may be fuzzy, but
I'm willing to bet that Team was
the only this summer at camp.
I can say across my 16 years at camp, Team
was the only black counselor in my group.
The American Camp Association states that
70% of summer campers are white Americans.
And this under represents the true figure
at private for profit sleep-away camps.
Across the entire camping landscape,
only 5% of camps cater to
a majority impoverished population.
It pains me to think about what it was
like for Tarzan Team to run around tying
shoes and applying band aids in a place
where no one looks like he did.
I won't presume to speak for him.
But I do know what it's
like to be the only.
Across three years majoring consulting
in 12 different projects, not once did
I have a black or Latinx supervisor,
team manager, or managing partner.
When I looked upwards,
craving a mentor that looked like me,
I struggled to find a business
leader I can connect with.
And now I'm here at the GSB and
I'm struck by this duality.
On one hand we learned so
much about the benefits of diversity.
Research right here at Stanford
tells us that diverse groups are 87%
better at making decisions.
A recent study by the Boston Consulting
Group says that diverse management
teams lead their companies
to 19% higher revenues.
Better at making money, better at
making decision and yet I still see so
much room for improvement.
Black and Latin X individuals attend
college 10 to 20% less than their
white peers.
Even with a degree,
Black college graduates earn 21%
less than their White classmates.
And this is exacerbated at the top.
Were racially diverse executives,
executives of any non-white American
background hold only 16%
of total C suite positions.
I want to see this change.
Creating and upholding diverse spaces
matters to me, because I dream of
seeing people in color in positions
of power, feeling they belong.
Expanding access to summer camp
can be a big part of this change.
I know because for me,
Camp made all the difference.
Camp allowed me to beat back that
Gremlin in my head screeching,
you're an imposter, you don't belong.
I remember back in middle school
when I was dealing with bullying,
Camp was the haven in which I could
prove to myself that I could be liked,
I could make friends I
could respond to adversity.
Simply Put Camp and its leaders like
Tarzy Team showed me I belonged.
And if I could go from outsider to
belonging at camp I sure as hell could do
it in the real world.
So we know we do well by our children
when we send them to Camp and
we know we do well by society when
we promote in uphold diverse spaces.
How do we bring these two truths together?
I could deliver a whole other talk
about what society can do to diversify
the Camp space.
From directing tax dollars to camp
initiatives, to increasing education for
minority parents about
the benefits of Camp.
and even yet
I can deliver this whole other talk about
the Camp industry could do to diversify.
From targeting more diverse camp directors
to increasing diversity, equity,
inclusion training for its staff.
But I want to focus on the here and now.
I want to focus on what you in this
room can do to expand access to
these crucially important
youth development programs.
First, send your kids to Camp and
do so thoughtfully.
You may not have kids now, but if in when
you do send them out there to play in
the woods, make mud balls and
stampede through the wilderness.
If that's not their thing, that's okay.
Send them to Basketball Camp, Theater
Camp, Science Camp, Woodworking Camp,
imaginary skateboarding with
a parrot on your shoulder camp.
The options are really endless.
But choose that camp deliberately.
Select a camp that upholds
a diverse environment.
Vote with your wallet and
demonstrate to camp owners and
directors across the nation.
That providing an enriching experience for
children of all backgrounds
is a business imperative.
And secondly,
donate to scholarship programs.
Just about every camp organization has
its own campership program focused on
expanding opportunity of access.
The truth is, however, many of these
slots go on applied for because minority
families either incorrectly
believe they can't afford camp or
are afraid to send their children away.
Certain nonprofit organizations
are addressing this issue by
directly matching inner city families
with residential summer camp programs.
Via donations from individuals like
you and me, organizations such as
the Guardsmen, Camp Piles, and
Project Mori, pay full camp tuition, so
that financial burdens don't bar children
from these life-changing programmes.
I'll confess,
diversifying the camp space won't fix all
the achievement gaps I mentioned earlier.
Even so, I can assert with
conviction that a summer at camp
can fundamentally shift
the life trajectory of a child,
It can show them they belong,
it did for me.
I started this talk by telling
you about Tarzan Team in
the power of an invested adult.
Now I'm asking you to
be that invested adult.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]